oh listeners we've been getting some
feedback that
our podcast is way too soy so
today's a podcast for the real men
pillpod
zack snyder real men
i've been extinct for thousands of years
the feminized modern audience only like
sitcom banter those marvel films with
their female characters
we're gonna throw in one character for
some banter
but i want the rest of you to be way
more gritty matt
you need to develop ambiguous commitment
issues and no more vodka sodas cause
that's a [ __ ] drink
that's right from now on only whiskey
with another whiskey down it
okay good that's your gritty power eric
what can you do
i guess i could throw in
a lot more needless exposition
and have less respect for our audience
so they understand i'm referencing the
great philosophers of all times
who had superior delineation between
good and bad
relative to our declining culture's
emphasis
on developmental causes for evil
characters that's some good exposition
now victor what's your gritty superpower
i will express rage at father figure
because i have lost the secondary female
character that curbed my overwhelming
edible rage
of course that is the only purpose of
female characters in
gritty podcasts i also need you to take
your shirt off victor
because you need to set a good example
[Music]
grab your video game controllers welcome
to the red pill pod
get them nips out i genuinely do think
that like whiskey with a whiskey chaser
sounds kind of appealing to be honest
with you
i only drink whiskey straight out of the
bottle
what's up listeners don't worry it's us
we're fine
we're fine spoilers ahead you might want
to skip forward
10 minutes because i watched
accidentally actually i didn't know what
it was i watched this steaming
pile of garbage called the zack snyder
cut
which i started at 11 o'clock because i
was like oh i'm gonna go to bed at one
how did you watch a four-hour film
exactly yeah that's that's crazy
like i sometimes accidentally watch an
episode of friends and i'm like oh
i guess i stepped out and spit it i
don't accidentally watch a four hour i
accidentally watched a four-hour movie
whoops cause men commit they don't stop
movies and watch the rest the next day
like [ __ ]
i am a completionist so i couldn't stop
until i had seen the whole thing but it
was like being in a stress position
where you're like i could hold this for
like 30 more seconds until you're just
in so much pain
and by the end of it i just felt like i
was being dragged behind
a pickup truck at a very slow speed
so getting road rash at like
40 kilometers an hour uh that ending was
really something
i don't watch any superhero movies so
like i i knew nothing i just saw you
guys were talking about this in the chat
about the snyder cut
and i was like what the hell and i had
no idea there's like this [ __ ] like
four
year like like campaign to re-release
like what was a shitty movie that came
out i guess in 2017 like i'm just
so out of the loop the only superhero
movies i've watched are like the batman
ones like the joker which does that even
count as a superhero movie that's like
the last one i watched
yeah if you use the term embracingly
enough yes the joker
this movie is only npcs
doing npc dialogue to each other what's
an mpc
the original budget character like they
have scripts
the budget for the first movie was 300
million dollars this is the one that was
released in 2017
and there's a huge flop the one the
version that was edited and released by
josh whedon
and they now devoted another 75 million
to patch this up which means this is
pretty much a 400 million dollar film
like not even including marketing that's
how much money was brought into justice
league
yeah i tell dc to get his [ __ ] back
together but i don't care enough
i just don't anymore so who watched it
i think everyone except you saw it you
saw it okay
but this is holy this is the easiest
freudian object i have ever seen in my
entire
life well yeah i mean the whole movie
basically revolves around characters
with [ __ ] daddy and parent problems
that's the whole theme okay spoiler
alerts ahead
but what's the great enemy what are the
objects called
some other boxes and by the way just for
the record i don't care that you're
spoiling it for me so go ahead
the mother boxes so let's just break
that down for a second
does it have to be any more on the nose
the mother box
is like this is this on purpose it's it
parodies itself the uterine cubes
so the great threat to these
hyper-masculine
shirt-off wearing whiskey bottle
drinking guys is the mother box
the great enemy object and then the
whole film
is just an analogy for the tortures and
anxieties of entering puberty
and losing the feminine mother and in
case that wasn't clear enough
the whole point at the end of the movie
is to enter a giant
fleshy oval-shaped object these
shirtless men have to penetrate
it in order to defeat the evil
not a lie oh my god what's this mother
box
what's that it brings chaos so it's a
living computer
and it's called the [ __ ] their
version of the infinity stones basically
this is like jordan peters this is like
jordan peterson like i like the chaos
it's the eternal feminine just by my
background for those of our listeners
who aren't aware of comic book history
so
darkseid and the new gods on which this
property is based we're conceived up by
jack kirby
in the 1970s this was after he left
marvel because he had a huge dispute
with stan lee
and they're widely considered to be
iconic characters and they are fantastic
but it's
fanta it's really important to note that
zack snyder is giving
a very very very alpha interpretation of
the material
more like uh i lost my mommy
interpretation
every character is raging at their
father this is it i was like
batman obviously has daddy issues 90
percent of the movie with superman
is like well i have daddy issues because
both my daddies are gone but my mom is
still alive
wonder woman has mommy issues flash
wants to get his dad out of prison
cyborg has like dad issues up the ying
yang
and aquaman also doesn't like his
surrogate father doesn't like his actual
mother
doesn't know who his final father is
quite yet like this is everybody's issue
right that's funny so it's just an
analogy for puberty for entertaining
15 year old males like we usually [ __ ]
on the 20 year old males
but this is for 15 year old males
is it weird that this is making me want
to see the movie you should
it is four hours of your life
if you do definitely see the first two
though
i guess actually at the first oh are you
serious really i've got to watch all
three movies before
is that necessary you you really don't
you really do it's true yeah you could
prob you could probably go in cold for
this one just because
it is do you think i'm gonna feel lost
if i like isn't it something to do with
like i did watch some ign video to get
me up to speed with what the snyder cut
was
and like i don't know is is it enough to
just know that like some aliens are
invading and then the justice league
it's just the plot of the avengers
except mommy issues
well the other thing about except for
with the exception of wonder woman
the only purpose of every female
character in the movie is to stop
the masculine rage so as soon as the
guy's mom dies he becomes like a a rager
throwing [ __ ] around hates his father so
and oh
superman comes back he's [ __ ] killing
everybody until he sees his uh
ex-girlfriend and his mommy so it's very
evident that the only purpose of any
female in this universe is to
hold back masculine rage which
coincidentally this is
exactly peterson's interpretation of the
movie beauty and the beast that
the woman needs to you know hold back
the rage from inside
god that's so cringy this movie
is like snyder's version to
whedon's version is like evil dead two
to evil dead one
it recapitulates the entire first one
goes way beyond it
it's a lot more fun but leaves you with
the same sort of emptiness afterwards i
guess
no i i do like bruce campbell though so
don't get me wrong it's more like uh
jordan peterson is to jung
just a rehash goes a bit further but
ultimately meaningless
well have you seen that has who here
seen batman versus superman
i guess you haven't victor i don't think
i know the movie is fascinating because
it basically in the un non-director's
cut
it's basically what you would expect a
drunk right-wing philosophy student to
come up with
if they were making a superhero movie at
like three in the morning
like everything is literally talking
heads spouting out
theological cliches then there's a bunch
of iron
[ __ ] thrown in talking about how these
people are like living gods amongst us
and how we don't know how to like bask
efficiently in their presence
then doomsday comes everybody dies and a
lot of stuff blows up at the end and
like
that this movie was like that on
steroids in the sense that
if the marvel films are kind of about
deconstructing the superhero arc a
little bit by making these people
quasi-human and kind of funny this was
really like no these people are a
[ __ ] huge
deal and you've got to treat them with
the same significance that like the
ancient athenians
treated their gods like that's what a
big deal these people are
they brought them back to life i can't
believe it
tell me more about this this fleshy this
fleshy thing that they have to enter
into
yeah they have to literally penetrate
the giant flesh
thing to take care of the female chaos
the mother
box okay how how much more on the nose
can you get
the uterine cubes the thing is i don't
think he meant to do any of it that's
what makes it so hilarious
it's ideology by the way funniest line
of the movie
very opening scene when it says
announces itself
um this movie is shot in four by four by
three
aspect ratio in keeping with zack
snyder's creative vision
what the [ __ ] does that mean the movie
was shot the movie was shot in four by
three are you kidding me that's so weird
christopher nolan is like i'm only going
to shoot in film because this is what
real men
shoot in and then this is just taking it
one level further no
we have to have a four by three aspect
ratio because
a wide screen is too vaginal maybe or
it's because he wants to remember when
he was a child then
all the tvs were four by three and it's
like it's like recapturing the childhood
the childhood wonder out watching a
superhero on your old four by three crt
tv
i'd i died it's also like i i've never
seen a movie
even like those dave old david lean
epics that actually is broken up into
parts that announced themselves with
like title cards
i don't know if you yeah there's
literally like a part of that weird
title
part two with the title part three that
was jarring yeah
that was so strange like part two and
then it names the chapter it's like yeah
i was just
like quentin tarantino that did that or
something i don't know
i thought it was gonna be a nice three
act film and that's why i was i kept
watching
until three in the morning because i was
like oh there can't be another one
no there's six parts and then an
epilogue
yeah and then like a 45 minute epilogue
with more mommy issues introduced
45 minutes of slow motion throughout the
whole movie too
they really could have well oddly enough
joker shows up at the very end for
really no goddamn good reason at all
just to promise a movie now that's never
going to come
and i found out that the set they think
to myself i'm like he's probably the
most mentally stable person in this
movie
because at least he doesn't seem to have
any edible issues going he's just like
yeah like i like to kill people it is
what it is everyone else here is
riven with neuroses and victor the
reason why the world is destroyed
in the epilogue is because superman's
girlfriend died
so she was she was holding back the rage
she let it go we're gonna get that movie
next but i don't know how you can be
so on the nose i have a question there
might be
actually because like this movie is very
successful sir
um yeah so matt i'm curious like like as
the probably the one who's the most
fan of superhero stuff here like i
wonder do you have
like i think this raises kind of a
question about like the the indulge
indulging in this kind of
like pleasure like these kinds of movies
that have these sorts of like ham-fisted
cheesy
uh things like what's like do you have a
defense for it or but at the same time
like
obviously there's the perspective of
just like you don't necessarily need a
defense for this but i just wonder how
you think about it
or position it in like your own sort of
intellectual uh
personal economy of your thinking well i
think that there is actually a good
reason to watch these things uh it's
kind of an anti-adornian reason
adorno's kind of insistence was that the
products of the culture industry are
used to
essentially bamboozle us uh and to
play into you know apathy uh towards our
social conditions
and i think these movies definitely play
at that role you can analyze it from
this level
but i actually think the kind of
approach that pills has taken this
giuseppe
ideology analysis is actually much more
interesting
because there's a reason these movies
are really popular and it's not just
because they're entertaining
uh it's because they speak to something
in people
probably something that people a lot of
us aren't even really conscious of and
analyzing them for that reason can tell
you a lot about where people's head
space is at
and it's worth noting that the kind of
plasticity of these characters itself is
kind of interesting
uh they kind of resemble sherlock holmes
in this respect and that
there have been many many different
interpretations of them uh
over the 70 80 years they've existed
and these interpretations don't just
vary widely in terms of
their aesthetics but also the kind of
political intention behind them
like batman has been everything from
like a
gothic film noir type anti-hero
who kind of stands against a corrupt
system to in this movie when he's
basically
[ __ ] zeus there to like reaffirm the
importance of patriarchy and the
security it provides us right
he's been put to all these different
purposes and he's also
like that way the hawkeye of this movie
and how much he actually sucks and can't
do anything yeah
that's true yeah basically it's like
there's superman and then there's this
guy with a grappling hook and a missile
that's true it's true i was kind of
curious because i think it's
maybe raises a question that could take
us towards our theme for the episode
if i even if we even have consensus and
what the theme for the episode is gonna
be that like
you know this kind of analysis of the
film
um you know heard by people like you
know people who aren't
uh you know theoretically educated who
aren't in the world of theory right like
it can be sometimes heard as like a
snobby rebuke of like
you know and to use a word pills used
when he was on epoch philosophies it's
like interrupting people's ability to
come like
in the sense of like enjoying these
things i think i said
nut nut nut yeah nut and like
interfering with our ability to not and
like i just think that that's an
interesting way into the
conversation right like in what way does
uncovering the nascent
uh sorts of like ideological content as
sort of revealing it to be like
one-dimensional or playing on tropes or
or put another way playing on sort of
like the repetitions of human behavior
like it's kind of
ignoble it's like an it's an ignoble
pointing out to like our in our like
sort of the pattern
following that we have and i don't know
maybe that we could use that as a way in
to the conversation okay so i'm gonna
introduce our two
methodolo our methodological foundation
for this
but before we move on and if there's any
other point to this movie i just saw
this movie as the most reactionary
steaming pile of [ __ ] i've ever seen and
the whole point of it is
we don't want no more sjw movies
we don't want any sitcom superhero
movies
like at the avengers when all the all
the women are charging together you know
all the women people
join up in the back we don't want any of
that [ __ ]
we want the good old days when like
superheroes were gods kind of like matt
was saying
but when it's reacting to is what our
actual topic for the day is
um moral art or the moral function of
art including film in this in this sense
the moral function of art
in our culture today because whoever
made this and likes this movie
hates that that film is moralizing
um and i think we probably disagree with
that often for
different reasons than this because this
is so on the nose
about it but um
like getting rid of the skunk in space
jam because
he's uh he's rape culture or whatever
um right this is that with that that
impulse is saying
like we need to protect the children we
need to control what people see because
if they see this happening in movies
then it's going to be the way
that they act out in real life and this
movie is saying
[ __ ] all that this is movies are for
for this purpose which is completely
antithetical to
uh art has a moral purpose so artisan's
moral purpose is going to be our topic
and this movie hates that [ __ ] it's a
good topic
i think if you look at the marvel films
the marvel films fall on a spectrum
somewhere between being
post-modern art or in some senses
post-post-modern art
kind of david foster wall as
communication and understanding is
really important
and they're interesting that way and
some of them are better than others
right uh what's interesting about this
film is it very emphatically
it rejects both kind of post-modern
approaches to superheroes and
post-post-modern approaches to
superheroes
but it doesn't want to go back to the
good old kind of christopher reeves
humanitarianism
uh that you saw with like the richard
donner phones with this naive innocence
because it sees that frankly as being
too soft too flaccid for
you know a man like zack snyder this is
supposed to be
uh like pill said a real in your face
these guys are better than you
and if a couple [ __ ] 100 million
people need to die for them to complete
their mission
then so be it because this struggle is
taking place at a metaphysical level you
can't understand
and i actually don't hate it i'll be the
first to admit that
i hate zack snyder's politics but he is
definitely a kind of popo tour of a
certain sense in that he has a vision
for what he wants to say
he's not just some director for hire and
in terms of his filmography if batman
and super vs superman was like a low
point
this is definitely much better at
expressing the kind of
randian quasi theological tropes he's
trying to get across
and as an object of ideology i think
it's interesting
i really do zack snyder have a public
politics i'm curious like
yeah it's not really coherent right i
mean i'm not going to sit there and say
that he's a philosopher right because
having watched batman vs superman i
don't really think he's read that deeply
into this
but he's talking about how he likes
people like iron rand before he's
definitely kind of
knowledgeable of this kind of young
campbell archetype
style stuff uh and so it's all kind of
thrown together here in a bit of a grab
bag but you can see why i'd be attracted
to it
if you think about it he's got eight
children which is kind of interesting
i'm just looking at his wikipedia and
i'm like wow that's a lot of children
for the modern age which maybe does
sometimes point to a politics actually
trad
and i should say it's worth noting uh
his daughter one of the reasons he
didn't originally release his cut is his
daughter committed suicide
in the filming of the original version
uh so he stepped away from the project
then because of fan demand he came back
and i think one of the reasons this does
work better than batman versus superman
is
he really he dedicated the movie to her
and you can really tell that it is a
passion project for him right like he
has a message
he's trying to convey with this film and
he feels it's important because she
sacrificed a lot for it
and you know the message is ridiculous
but as you know a piece that's trying to
get it across i think it conveys that
message effectively if that makes sense
eric what you saying i mean what what
can i say
i i didn't find the movie very
aesthetically
interesting so on that point alone i
basically don't
care about thinking about the movie
because it's not aesthetically
interesting so how could it really have
a politically interesting point
and it doesn't it's pure escapism it's
fantasy
there's nothing going on in this film
like even less so
than in the christopher nolan movies
it's less political
than those movies it's completely
detached from reality
it's not aesthetically interesting the
actors in it are just
oh my god like like gal gadot tweeting
about
the idf i don't know [ __ ] batman
i don't know why they got him to play
batman he's just a brutal person
yeah i just don't like him at all and
then that's two of the principal actors
right there
that i just can't stand the most
interesting character was definitely
cyborg victor he was pretty [ __ ] cool
and they should have just made the whole
movie about him
and not tried to cram the joker in or
anything like that
i mean that's the problem it it felt
like a director's cut
of a movie that's already been done it
felt like they were trying to do
everything
marvel has already done and is now
moving past
with cool [ __ ] like legion and like the
first half of wanda vision
and those sorts of weird territories
that marvel is
driving into where dc is still just
struggling
to pick up making a half decent [ __ ]
movie on a consistent basis
rather than actually like exploring this
morally bankrupt aesthetic of
superheroes
which marvel's already done and dc just
can't seem to get right
so i don't know what moving forward i
don't i think they should just leap over
this
epic ensemble [ __ ] that x-men and
avengers did
like 20 [ __ ] years ago did it well
enough we don't need any more of that
[ __ ]
go in a new [ __ ] aesthetic direction
get christopher nolan back if you have
to get someone who knows how to direct a
[ __ ] movie
and do it i thought what this movie was
was like what a 13 year old thought
was really good about the avengers and
then just amped up because it has
totally like eric said there was nothing
it had
not a single understanding of human
conversation human motivation human
behavior there was not even a trace of a
person
in this movie it was preposterous
well but i think this actually
demonstrates the problem with so we say
archetypal ways of approaching cinema
because i actually do think
again as a piece of pop art it's
interesting i think it's devoid of
deeply resonant value in the way that
eric is talking about
but the reason it works for people is
because it does
appeal hard to a certain sense of what
these archetypes are trying to
accomplish which is precisely to
elevate the kind of psychological
conflicts these people are dealing with
above
normal human emotions and their nuances
right like if you think about this
everything in this movie is amped up
emotionally to a 20 right
steppenwolf wants to please his daddy
figure bruce wayne needs to prove it
like to prove something to his dead
parents and they really don't care that
much about
the actual human circumstances of this
conflict and who it's impacting
what matters is their kind of epic clash
over their different pathologies their
pathologies
their pathologies would be what a 13
year old thinks pathologies are
that's it well that's it it's basically
if you had a 13 year old who reads
i don't know um the thief and plays you
know the oedipus myth and was like
oh that's pretty cool there's like this
sphinx and then like he kills his father
man like
there's some deep [ __ ] going on here i'm
going to make a film about that
it's the same kind of idea right but
again i think it's interesting that this
kind of
extremely hyper real approach to
archetypal filmmaking
devoid of kind of nuance and substance
is becoming really resonant to people
but i know maybe that's just me i kind
of think that this development is
culturally interesting well i'm curious
like so how does that fit into
because something pills said earlier
that i think is interesting we should
actually get to the topic of moralizing
in film
because like this is like a hyper real
spectacle but then we have
other movies that are presumably also
hyper real spectacles but have like uh
like more of a moralization or they're
more they're accused of of kind of like
ham-fisted
attempts to push forward i don't know
like
like dumb things that that like um
stupid like reactionary
uh like intellectual dark web kids like
complain about like star wars having
more people of color or whatever like
like dumb [ __ ] like that but
well this is actually where the debate
about this whole franchise came in i'm
not sure if you're aware of this but man
of steel came out which is the first
snyder verse movie
and superman i'm probably not aware of
it sorry superman in that movie fights
against his other daddy figure in this
one
odd right and he has basically three
daddy figures in this one
his actual daddy has adopted daddy and
the attempted daddy
uh general zod right and in the comp the
context of this edible conflict
hyperradical conflict
he completely [ __ ] demolishes
metropolis just
wipes it out and doesn't care and he
kills zod in the end and there's all
nice
but this created a huge backlash on par
on the part of people who like the
marvel films because they said like
he's not actually acting like a quote
hero like he's not trying to save
anybody
he doesn't actually make an effort to
like rescue civilians
he just like [ __ ] throws them through
buildings and he's like whatever if
there's a couple thousand civilian
casualties
whatever the [ __ ] um and is this again
really divine
conflict in snyder's mind and this kind
of 13 year old vision
and that became really controversial uh
because people are like they're not
acting like
good liberal heroes are supposed to
right where the episodes should be on
saving the everyday man and so they kind
of backed off on this a little bit in
batman versus superman uh because they
tried to kind of suggest that they're
maybe saving people
but what's interesting about this movie
as pill says it goes right back to this
kind of
hyper archetypal filmmaking you know
what i mean where
really the mundane people of the world
don't matter what's of concern is these
people dealing with their psychological
conflicts
through beating the [ __ ] out of this
giant vaginal um
construct uh and then destroying the
mother within
you know okay so we're gonna leave that
behind now
uh i have a big summary written down
here because we haven't talked about
psychoanalysis much or sociology almost
at all
so i'm just gonna try to give us uh
our listeners and us a methodological
thing to stand on for this or for this
topic at least
so this is a film this pod this gritty
podcast
so the theoretical method that we
are going to use because we've talked
about this already um
are psychoanalysis and sociology and the
way that those two
interact so we've got psychoanalysis
freud mostly most people know what's up
with that
that started clinical deals with
individuals in the clinic
and then unrelated at the same time very
early
20th century and a few decades prior
sociology is becoming a discipline
so a lot of theorists have dealt with
what we now call sociology like marx
would be an example of someone who's a
sociologist
but looking backwards retrospectively he
becomes that
but early 20th century it's max weber
german
and emile durkheim french these are the
two
founders of sociology and the common
thread between
them that i think is relevant to the
discussion here is that both weber and
durkheim
analyze culture what we now call culture
as a specific
different field and what's important to
them
is the way that culture relates to
religion because early 20th century of
course is when
western culture is being secularized in
a way that hasn't
ever happened before so they were very
attuned to those distinctions
and religion had a very clearly defined
and dominant
place in uh european north american
culture and that was moral instruction
more or less uh you can push back on
this i think eric's gonna push back on
this later but
we're getting a clear uh a lo-fi
rendering so
then when we have no moral authority or
no religious authority anymore
then for durkheim and weber those
functions that religion pushed or
its purpose in society didn't disappear
it just moved to other dimensions of
society so obviously looking forward
we're we're saying that this is now in
the hands of uh
film particularly because it's our most
totemic
cultural manifestation of it so
we really don't have any because we have
no religion we have no unifying
totems anymore except stuff like
hollywood blockbusters
so then my question to you is then uh
the panel i guess uh this burden is now
being put on
art and culture warriors whether it's
conservatives
uh locusts or whatever they disagree
on what the function of art should be
but it seems to be
at least seems to me that they do agree
that art has moral value and that it
should be judged on
moral grounds whether those grounds are
good or evil
but they do have a moral function and
this is presumably if we take the
sociological thesis because
religion has fled so now the functions
of art
particularly totem and taboo which is
where psychoanalysis comes back into
this freud's book totem and taboo
written on by durkheim but now that now
our
pop culture what we call pop culture has
the function that religion
used to have so we have new priests new
totems
new taboos new rules but they don't come
from religion anymore they come from
this
vacuous space called culture which
didn't really exist in the same way that
we
discuss it prior all right so
totem taboo that's a provisional method
of interpreting
you know the moral value of art and with
that i'll just throw it out to you guys
i want to make history jackie an
injunction though and say that the truly
radical psychoanalytical
act would have act would actually be for
us to interrogate why we've been
avoiding
this topic for such a long time and the
only conclusion i can reach is that we
haven't want to talk about
psychoanalysis because we're all
repressing some deep sexual urges uh
that haven't been acknowledged yet
that's why it's taken us so long to get
this topic and pills should be ashamed
that he's not willing to acknowledge his
own efforts to avoid it i'm glad you're
so self-aware
but you're not really repressing very
i'm pretty sure you're sexual
i was just gonna say you have not been
repressing any of your sexual urges at
all
yeah that's because i'm more
psychoanalytically healthy than you
right i'm
in touch with my own head oh yeah sure
um yeah i mean one thing i would say is
it seems like these
the moralization or the the function of
art sort of competing
totems i guess well that maybe that's
the difference right like now the pop
culture there's like a competing between
i guess the more locusts or
conservatives for what art art what kind
of totems art should produce right and
there's
that's why we see a reaction against
trying to like whatever awoke eyes
certain pop culture pop cultural icons
you see uh conservatives like uh you
know
and anti-locust types getting all
reactionary against it because
it's interfering with the totems that
they want uh to be in in in the pop
culture that they consume
yeah like my kind of response to this is
i think it's important not to kind of
over
nichianize uh our approach uh to art and
culture right and i can completely
understand why pills is doing so since
roy himself was deeply influenced by
nietzsche and in a lot of his later work
like today and the future of illusion he
does talk about
the role that that religion plays in
coding
uh are different psychic um motivations
uh in a way that sometimes becomes
interesting enough mysterious to us
ourselves right in the same way god is
rejected as being mysterious uh to human
beings even though we're the ones who
create the idea of god
right uh but it's worth knowing that roy
thought that these were universal human
impulses
uh that you find regardless of any kind
of cultural context because
they have a kind of neural basis to them
uh that goes beyond
even your cultural activities and so on
and so forth and this is one of the
reasons why he really felt compelled to
try to
insist uh that psychoanalysis was a
science and one of the things that i've
always thought most interesting
about this is uh it shows you how it is
that a lot of the stuff that it covers
really falls into this grade area since
a lot of people are determined to also
say it's not a science
right uh i'm not sure that it is i think
it really depends on your definition of
science
right but it's worth noting that the
kind of
backlash that this generated and all the
controversy surrounding it has been
going
on for a hundred years now and you still
haven't seen any silence on the matter
i'm curious though do you think that um
because
like earlier the way pills set it up
right it's like you have the locusts and
like the conservatives and it's like a
battle for the for the totems of culture
but then when it comes to art do you
also think maybe there's this third camp
of people who are like
trying to be like artistic purists who
are saying like you know art shouldn't
have
anything to do with the totems that that
art just has to be a pure expression of
like that there's something there's
something like there's something that
exists that is like some sort of
artistic expression that is just like
freed from and like that's a different
idea
well i think this is what comes across
most likely nicely in uh
young's term where he talks about depth
psychology right because one of the
things that you saw conventional
romantic art criticism
uh was this distinction between high art
and low art right art that reaches a
kind of profound depth
and art that's just superficial and glib
and i'm not saying that we should
abandon that standard because i think
that there are certainly things that are
of superior aesthetic quality that speak
more deeply to human nature
however you want to conceive of that but
one of the things that's interesting
about deaf psychology is precisely that
even what seems like mundane works of
art like pop art for example
can actually conceal really important
psychoanalytic truths
right uh in fact they can be most
interesting if they
are expressed in terms of pop or other
totemic symbols
uh precisely because then what happens
is a lot of these psychoanal truths
rather than be made explicit
as you find in great art it's coded
symbolically so you have to actually
work to unpack it right like it's very
easy to understand what
nietzsche means by the superman compared
to trying to understand what superman
means in the general culture
right because nietzsche was pretty
explicit about what he took to superman
to mean
where superman clark kent whatever right
uh is symbolic included in so many
different ways that he could spend a
lifetime just trying to unpack them all
yeah it's uh it's it it's
like you've set up you set up a a film
or
a piece of literature as a dream and
you analyze it like it's a dream is that
is that not how
you know you know freud used to want to
be a writer and then that didn't work
out for him so he became a psychologist
and considered himself a man of science
and worked out this science of the human
mind
but then afterwards of course people
took up his
theories and applied them to literature
and art and culture
and all sorts of other things rather
than just the individual
in the clinical setting i mean in
in a way my head's spinning a little bit
because of how
sort of complicated some of this is
i mean is art supposed to be do we
moralize about
art and try to draw moral truths or
consequences from it or
do we let art do the moralizing for us
in a sense and so we just read off what
culture is what the human psyche is all
about
from our artworks do we try to impose
like limitations on what art
should and shouldn't be able to do in
the good society i mean in a way this is
just the the ancient
sort of conversation between plato and
aristotle over
the role of the poets in a good society
well i think this is where it gets
really interesting though and delusion
qatar
uh leveled a really great critique uh
psychoanalysis that pelz has talked
about in this video so people should
check that out i should say
one of the things that's interesting
when it comes to whether or not more art
should have a moral intention
right uh is that what psychoanalysis
really brings to the fore are two
different
turns right uh one is this idea that we
should be
less moralistic about some things and a
lot of people see freudianism
as really liberating for art in this
sense right and that allows us to
express
ideas that we weren't able to express
before by ceasing to make them taboo
but one of the things that dng point out
is that one of the problems with
freudianism
and psychoanalysis generally is it also
opens space for us to be moralistic
about far more intensely personal
matters
than we were before uh and if you think
about this i
this use of the term sick to describe
certain people right what we're really
talking about now is individual people's
pathology the way they think who they
are how their psyche operates
and a lot of contemporary arc now
pathologizes and moralizes
about certain characters in this way
right describing not just their actions
as bad
but their inner psyche is somehow sick
or warped or not
functioning properly and i think this is
really
the good thing and the bad thing about
psychoanalysis and the kind of way that
it's influenced art on the one hand
nobody's gonna sit there and give you
[ __ ] for talking about sexual issues
anymore or
the deep problems that are found in
human relations but on the other hand
you can have movies that really condemn
certain people as deviants
right uh as an example like like a
contemporary example of a movie because
i
well i'm trying to think of something
that's vulgar in that way because a lot
of the examples i can think of are about
deviant pathologies but are actually
good like their intentions that's what
i'm saying
explaining it like taxi drivers what
immediately came to mind and i'm like
he's definitely criticizing his
pathology but it's in an interesting way
and in a way that i think is good i'm
trying to think of
one that does this kind of vulgarly
because i thought is it also isn't like
the contemporary trend in movies
to kind of almost like not glorify but
like add a more positive like like the
edgy character who's got all these
pathologies is actually to sometimes
turn into like a complicated hero
yeah i think it's more um that's a very
contemporary
phenomena right a lot of just the
original context of
where psychoanalysis comes from and what
its role
is you know like in duluth and guterree
call them the sort of new priestly class
like we were talking about sociology
kind of posits this idea
where secularism and capitalism is going
to take over
all the things that religion was doing
health
and education and spiritual basic
spirituality
and soul doctoring is the last sort of
thing
for the uh for the for for the church to
take over but
then you have these this array of
disciplines that emerges
you have sociology which studies
advanced civilizations
and non-western civilizations you have
anthropology which studies
primitive people and then you have
psychoanalysis
which studies you know deviance within
within modern societies and and the art
of correcting
deviant characters and personalities
within
a modern society and trying to mold them
into
whatever you want to say productive
members of society people without
such severe neuroses that they can't
function
in a competitive modern sort of social
media
so psychoanalysis is like
i mean in the broadest sense it's it's
sort of modern culture
turned back against itself and looking
at its own deviance and trying to
correct that and then of course
later when you get to later thinkers
like lacan and like
toulouse and guterree you start to
question that role of psychoanalysis and
try to open it up
to more therapeutic avenues more
sort of avenues that will push people
towards
a healthy positive life rather than just
like
being absent from ptsd or something like
that right i thought of an example and i
just want to bring it up
before someone jumps in it uh so sex in
the city uh is probably the best example
i can think of
uh that pertains to what i was talking
about victor because
what's interesting about that show is
this
the people in it accept certain
deviations from conventional sexual
moors
right and even tend to embrace them uh
you know they're very open about their
sexuality
they're trying to embrace alternative
sexuality so-called they even see
uh sexuality is something that's kind of
hip right
uh at the same time any kind of deviance
from neoliberal ideology right
uh as presented in the another kind of
90s 1990s early 2000s kind of golden era
is seen as going way too far and it's
almost always
criticized both by the people on the
show and by the show itself
right as that's not what it is that we
want that's just kind of sick or wrong
or
useless in some way shape or form uh and
it's a nice kind of distillation i think
of the problem is there any examples in
the show like cause
cause i can't i mean i don't know that
[ __ ] i mean sex in the city is a good
example because it gives like
from what i can gather anyway gives a
representational
critique of the madonna [ __ ]
complex now if you don't know what that
is not [ __ ] shaming
but freud says that for some men
it's a complex you can only see women
as either madonna which is you know pure
wifey material untainted or
a [ __ ] which is then something that you
use and discard so male gay stuff
psychoanalytic film criticism susan
sontag
gays stuff and kind of the
the cultural function of sex in the city
is that each of these women have
different desires different goals they
certainly
break the archetypical pair of
madonna [ __ ] complex and it's uh by
virtue of that critique
and empowerment of women that have you
know goals ranging from
being a wife to being a career person
and that would be an example of
representational
critique in that sense that we also have
the psychologization
of the villain at the same time
maleficent that evil character from
sleeping beauty she got her own movie
that shows
why she became evil joker shows why
like th there's causes environmental
causes for why people act the way they
do girls
yeah i've never seen it they're
jokerfying cruella deville now carola
deville's just an evil person who wants
to skin puppies
but now she's going to have like a
backstory that explains why
yeah 13 reasons why is another one right
i mean
the suicide of the main character in
that is treated as sympathetically right
that she had an internal life that
was deeply repressed by bullying all
around her
but some of the characters in the show
like the heroin addict who's poor and
winds up becoming a junkie
that's far more criticized right because
even though he has good reasons for
doing what he's doing
he's deviating too far and he doesn't
have is not
dealing with the kind of neuroses that
we expect in a late capitalist society
in the
proper way okay so now we're doing
something different though because those
are
the movies performing like an analytic
function
for the audience they're performing as
the analysis saying
or the analyst we have this person
that's up till now been a stock
character
they just appeared evil or they appeared
to be you know
a sexual deviant or whatever kind of
deviant but now we're going to give
their backstory so that you can
like truly understand them but then we
have the other
side of this as a totem where people
watch this show and say
you're glorifying violence or you're
justifying
um toxic masculinity or you're
justifying rape culture by having this
skunk who always
tries to perform to the little kitty
you're perpetuating femme feminine
tropes yeah
damaging right right of the the madonna
horror binary
or the chaotic the chaotic like [ __ ] or
something
like yeah no absolutely right now i
think this is something that gj
catches on to very well right where it
points out that
in our liberal tolerant post-freudian
society it's not like we've gotten away
from taboos
right some things are less taboo than
they were before
right you'd never find somebody who's
going to criticize you for an acceptable
sexuality that would deviate from
conventional puritan sexual morality
any longer right at least not in many
communities um
but things like not accepting someone's
identity even if you're critical of
certains as their moral values
becomes a lot more problematic to
navigate right um
in our contemporary environment and art
expresses that uh
very nicely i think yeah
i was curious like um you know pills
like do you think art is like the
because i i mean i really wanted to talk
maybe we won't talk about it in this
episode but i feel like it fits like i
mentioned earlier like like
the role that certain kinds of cultural
things like art
work to um kind of perpetuate people's
internal like economy of satisfaction
right in like a psychoanalytic sense
and earlier like you know that joke
about like interrupting people's ability
to nut like i like i feel like it's
interesting to think about the role
that art and like these totems are
playing in people's internal
ability to feel like the sense of
satisfaction and like the ways that they
there's like a kind of battle over
the economy of this of like of of of
nutting
right like kind of internally that the
satisfaction that
the the economy of nut like the way that
that that
media and art plays in in people's like
own
internal sort of narratives libidinal
economy
yeah libidinal economy right i like this
idea i think of interrupting people's
ability to not because that's that's
what we're doing when we criticize works
of art
in a way we're trying to do that but it
like i am often very thankful in in a
kind of mixed way because it's like oh
great you just ruined this thing i liked
for
me but i mean i'm glad you pointed it
out like one of the big revelations in
my life was growing up
as i really loved the lord of the rings
movies and then one day somebody pointed
out to me and said hey did you notice
that there's not a single person of
color
in that entire [ __ ] trilogy and i
said oh my
god i would look back at the movie i
said i think maybe some of the orcs are
brown people
but otherwise this is bad so the
haradrim
described in the book are described as
like having black skin
and i remember watching like the
directors or
the directors commentary of lord of the
rings
and one of the women said we don't want
another evil race that's black so
we didn't make them black but they're
just nondescript
persian or middle eastern something like
good job you got the moral high ground
now but she was proud of herself
yeah they're they either appear as like
evil guys in makeup
or with their faces covered but none of
the protagonist
races in lord of the rings are people of
color and of course i think they fixed
that a little bit and like the hobbit
trailer yeah some
pointed that out to me and it it blew my
mind or even
growing up i loved watching the i loved
watching the hercules the legend
continues with kevin sorbo
and now i look at kevin sorbo's recent
work and he's a right-wing
[ __ ] nut job who who picks only
movies that have an extremely strong
conservative message like i think one of
his last movies
was a disaster movie about how society
is crumbling and liberals are coming to
take all their guns
and they need to protect their guns it
was worse it's that basically the
liberals take away the guns
as a precondition for establishing their
dictatorship
and then they heroically fight against
them with crossbows and other things to
get the guns back but i
it's crazy yeah in any case are you
saying that the art is a totem
or that you saw it as a totem and now
you're being like morally educated
by them or how does that change your
interpretation
i mean people together when we criticize
art and we discuss these things like i
said earlier
with sort of i'm i've always been
somebody who's very aware of the
the israel-palestine situation and then
when someone like gal gadot
tweets these uncritically pro-israeli
things
it makes it hard for me to enjoy any
film that she's in afterwards and i was
making the same point about kevin sorbo
i can no longer go back and enjoy my
childhood
because these [ __ ] people exist and
it's like i either have to be completely
apolitical
and be like oh my god i'm so excited
blink 182 release some new [ __ ]
be like a [ __ ] ding dong and listen
to that [ __ ]
or i i just i can't enjoy modern culture
because it's all just permeated by
[ __ ] people with their own agendas
trying to make money yeah and
and then i agree with like adorno in the
end and saying this is all just a
[ __ ]
show to get your money stop buying into
it
and criticize to your heart's content
because ultimately
it's going to be good for you it's going
to be good for other people even if
you're wrong just put some ideas out
there
and so i often find myself having
trouble even
working myself up to have a reaction to
these [ __ ] movies anymore because
they're just
so all the return of the same they're
just [ __ ]
yeah i hate it so i i may i offer too i
have so i actually have in front of me
here uh like bruce fink's uh
introduction to lacanian psychoanalysis
and he has like a nice explanation at
the beginning and i feel like
it could map on to like what we're
seeing in the shift of culture
he talks about like how people go to
therapy and moments when they have a
crisis in their ability to have set to
have the continual satisfaction that
they had before right they say
it's at the at times when their modus
apparently is breaking down
and the the symptom used to provide a
substitute satisfaction but these
substitutes stop working
in some way and it comes in this into
conflict with society at large
um so i guess i wonder whether like we
can think about this shift that's
happening more
questioning an undermining of like the
role that cultures
are playing because it's not playing the
role anymore that it could before it was
giving us a kind of sustained
satisfaction
and now all these questions right that
we're asking about
you know is there enough representation
of this person are they actually like
were these older movies that we used to
enjoy actually
somehow perpetuating some like whatever
myths about things that we we now
disagree with right it's interrupting
it's interrupting our ability to enjoy
them anymore um
and now i think maybe what we're seeing
in the sort of culture war
right is that we're seeing more like
wokest
people being like yeah we need to
undermine these things so we can create
new art that's gonna actually
lead to a new economy of satisfaction
and then the more conservative
reactionary type is like
i don't like that was working for me
before i was getting that satisfaction
and that jewish sons from that and now
you're trying to ruin it
for me well i'm like [ __ ] you i hate you
i think they get the jewish songs
from being upset that the other person
oh that's true
that's true too why the [ __ ] would you
draw
like culture warlines over baby it's
cold outside
and dr seuss but isn't that actually
what's happening that's the substitute
desires like before the art was like
they were happy with their little
culture
but now the way that they're
substituting that is the rage that they
feel
right yeah yeah that's the substitute
for what was working before
i want to say that i think eric could
have something really good and i'll link
this with your comment also victor about
this culture war stuff because you know
you're right about the blink 182 thing
and psychoanalysis right because on the
one hand
people initially interpreted for
audiences as this really liberating
uh kind of effort that you think would
create something like take off your
pants and jackets with
songs about jacking off and everything
right because freudianism exposes that
we're all thinking about this all the
time
and there's nothing particularly
immature about engaging in it or
thinking about it right
on the other hand then freudianism
evolves to actually being a kind of
insistence on maturation
right that you shouldn't just be
enjoying things
uncritically because that might be
giving in to your own worst pathologies
you need to discipline yourself and try
to deal with your actual problems
so you start to like the right things
not just the wrong things
but this is really interesting because
now you see a kind of moralistic shift
from the original emancipatory intention
to a kind of injunction that you
actually can't just behave a certain way
you need to think and feel a certain way
we need to on the one hand to interpret
it as a liberating
kind of approach to the study of the
human psyche uh while at the same time
that comes to detention which is
with its insistence that you need to be
self-critical about your own
pathological inclinations
and i'm not really sure that there's an
easy way to square
either of these kind of dimensions uh to
the psychoanalytic porn
right and the way that this relates back
to the kind of culture war stuff
is that i think that most progressives
tend to like to approach psychological
issues
from a liberatory standpoint right
there's this idea that
once we kind of unmask ideology we'll be
liberated to think about it in a new way
and we can create
new kinds of sexuality new kinds of
identity you know you name it up the yin
yang
but conservatives tend to approach this
from a kind of ethical moralistic
standpoint right where
the lesson of psychoanalyst would be
necessarily that you should
give up these initial inclinations and
try to
mature yourself into a good stable
member of society
the the substitute satisfaction that i
was talking about
is i think what's interesting on the
like woke us side
of it is that the substitute
satisfaction i think that now we're
seeing is
is actually in the condemning right so
like it's in the condemning of something
for like not sufficiently like
fulfilling whatever
sorts of values that's now where the
status of the substitute satisfaction is
right it's like no longer
the art isn't doing that anymore it's
like actually being able to call it out
and then the conservative is like
in like the reaction to that they get
their substitute satisfaction
so it's like it's like it's like i guess
the point is it's not even really about
the
art anymore well yeah it's symbolic now
like the
condemning is a symbolic gesture it's
not political because if it was
political you'd take all the books
and burn them or you excommunicate or
or export the uh whatever whoever made
it to another country and you may
do an actual political act but today we
just
satisfy ourselves with symbolic acts of
condemnation
we know we're all with the condemnation
yeah because we're all shut up in this
culture sphere where everything we do
is symbolic and nothing really [ __ ]
matters or makes any other difference
and all we do is just we we argue about
these things on social media
which is exactly what social media
corporations want us to do and they make
money off of it and they show us
advertisements
while we do it meanwhile we're all just
these [ __ ] suckers
who think that arguing about cultural
products like films actually makes a
difference
in life i don't i don't know if it
really does i do i do
think bringing a critical spirit is
valuable to that but
i mean in from the larger picture i mean
all of this is just culture and it's a
product
of very carefully calculated investments
and returns
it has nothing to do with in like almost
helping people enjoy things and get
through their lives and
be entertained is almost a secondary
consequence of this
drive to make money and it all like what
does it all mean
i don't know one thing eric you said is
if we
actually cared if we were sufficiently
material about
these products you would destroy it
because by destroying it
you pulverize its exchange value
out of existence so you don't need to
deal with that anymore but if it's a
hyper real economy then
the thing has sign value and you want to
like perpetuate its sign value
by giving it all these investments so it
might even be
like a calculated decision on behalf of
gillette or whatever to say we're gonna
have like
don't let the boys fight because that's
just that's like
what our advertisements made us look
like 20 years ago like you gotta take
your shirt off and look sexy while
you're shaving
no we're gonna have like a positive
image of masculinity
but they probably did that or probably
somebody knew that they did that to piss
enough people off so that this could
become a trending topic
so it's the sign value of these things
that really matters because if it did
matter to whoever censuring at
a given time you would try to destroy
the object
and partially because it's all digital
it's impossible but this
the circulation of science has value in
that context
very much a part and we could call it
like part of us
about a commodities signed value is this
morality
mechanism the morality is like a
variable of
how how trending a topic is so maybe
we're feeding into that with the zack
snyder
commodity which is a completely
reactionary one but we're talking about
it for a reason
and since you can't destroy it the only
gesture left
is cancel it because that's all you can
do because you can't physically destroy
something that exists on 10 million
computers at the same time and the cloud
so you just cancel it and then well it's
even a little more than that canceling
it
gives the thing more value exactly
exactly and right now
canceling has has very specific
connotations and it's a and it's
just more fuel on the fire in a way when
people try to
say let's say cultural boycott instead
of canceling but it's the same deal
right well space jam back in the news
yeah exactly well i wanted to make a
distinction between two different films
that i think
expressed this kind of distinction
victor was talking about between uh
like reactionary conservative approaches
to psychoanalysis versus left-wing ones
right
because in my mind the best well-known
kind of left-wing movie uh that came out
over the last 25 years
was fight club right uh and that's a
very second one
yeah zack snyder is well known for being
a kind of democratic socialist right
fight club
fight club yeah wasn't it yeah yeah
david fincher sorry david fincher sorry
yeah not sex either because
that's my other example is that phone so
you know the plot of fight club is
basically somebody who first has to
overthrow the symbolic universe
that's kind of over determining his
identity uh
but when he does that he kind of was
immediately tempted by
reactionary potentials right uh embodied
in tyler durden right
brad pitt it comes to him offering this
kind of macho uh rebellion against
femininity
and also against the contemporary
culture and it's only by finally doing
away with that that he's able to
undertake a genuinely revolutionary act
uh which is to kind of do what he's
wanted to do the entire time
which is basically to have sex with
helena bona carter without there being
all kinds of problems with it
right while the credit card companies
blow up and i see this as a really
emancipatory movie as
uh fincher intended it and as the
original author chuck pollenhawk
also wanted it to be right if you
compress that with something like zack
snyder's justice league
all the kind of pathological
activity engaging and then trying to
blow up these vaginal symbols
and just beat the crap out of each other
and with the symbolic universe that
pre-existed this conflict being
reaffirmed
and re-stabilized right uh and it ends
with this kind of nostalgic montage
of all these heroes going back to what
they were doing before because
fundamentally the idea is that the world
didn't really need to be changed
it just needed to be re-solidified and
now we can also appreciate the people
who've defended the status quo
from feminine chaos yeah exactly save
from feminine chaos
so i think this really demonstrates the
kind of difference in filmmaking
approaches in pop art
right on the one hand you have this guy
who has to basically
liberate himself even from his own
drives towards fascism
in order to genuinely become free and
get what he wants to fulfill his desire
in the lacanian sense or to pursue his
desire and never give up on it in the
coming sense
versus this kind of jungian approach to
filmmaking you see in zack cider's
justice league which is
everything is fine the way it is our
pathologies emerge because we're unable
to accept it
and chaos sometimes entered and our
battle is to try to
re-situate ourselves uh in a conformance
way to the status quo
just very quickly it's interesting
because most of the readings i've heard
of fight club call it just like a
reactionary like
like glorification of masculine
masculinity but like you're right
it's just that's just interesting well
the original author i should say is gay
right
chuck paulinho and he's been on record
of saying that he hates those
interpretations because he points out
like tyler durden is not a hero
right tyler durden is like a fascist
icon that's the mystery
of misinterpretation of that movie is
that tyler durden has to get
shot and that's the that's like the
heroic moment
but exactly the whole movie i mean to
to dissuade matt's interpretation a
little bit it does make him
look really [ __ ] cool oh it does if
tyler durden had directed a movie
it would be zack snyder's justice league
yeah it's true it's true that's why i
like the movie though like he just like
as a movie that kind of explores the
fascination of fascism
to like a certain kind of intelligent
male
like it's really good because exactly
you watch the movie you're like brad
pitt is [ __ ] awesome
right just [ __ ] the greatest really
interesting to
me that you just brought it there by the
way this is not planned
but i do have a youtube video
coming out that references both tyler
durden and zack snyder
in about the same sentence and it's
already done yeah it's already uploaded
so it's not influenced by this
discussion perfect
perfect that movie should just be called
brad pitt's body because that's what
it's really all about
it's not about anything oh yeah that
scene with him in the cigarette where he
just like beats the crap out of the guy
i'm not gonna lie there was a small part
of me and that was
oh yeah here we go here we go again here
comes the russian
it was more like the party wanted me to
put on a helmet and invade troy
is what it made me want to do the part
of me that like mildly like when i was a
teenager was bought into this alpha
stuff was i'm like yeah he's alpha is
[ __ ] look at that right you know my soul
he is
this is the point of him yeah this is
the 20 this is also like the 20 year
old's interpretation of
nietzsche nietzsche is like you need to
overcome everybody else
sucks blow up your condo and go start a
fight club and then they miss that the
final scene of that movie is him
shooting tyler durden in the head
yeah exactly and again what i think is
really important about this movie and
where i think bitcher is really
innovative
is again the entire movie what he really
wants is to be with helena bona carter
who's basically perfect for him right
she's the same kind of personality she
understands where he's coming from
but he cannot do that until he's able to
he cannot get what he's been trying to
pursue this entire time until he
destroys not just you know the kind of
symbolic order that's oppressing him
outside of himself
but the kind of inner fascist within
that's the last step achieving
we are sort of all over the place on the
psychoanalytic spectrum here too because
tyler durden
is i mean in classical terms he's the id
right he's the yeah that's true he's the
it he's the thing he's
he's what what supposedly all humans
harbor
in their deepest darkest selves in their
hearts of hearts well
i mean women men everybody has this sort
of
this dangerous level of uh of aggression
and sexual energy that has to be
channeled into positive things but when
we're talking about morality
whatever your preferred job we're
talking about you want to be brad pitt
let's just be
let's just affirm that yeah yeah great
cheese on that body
that you you want to talk about with
morality
the super ego and you know the law of
the father
and that's and then the ego is really
just sort of the conscious
life that we're taking in but with all
these other forces under the surface so
we internalize
the superego as a kind of moral voice
and we are in this internal conflict
with the id
the it that always wants to emerge and
release this energy that's going to
destroy society or
threaten the social order in various
ways so when we're bringing it down to
the basics i mean that's what i see is
the sort of
spread of psychoanalytic concepts and if
fight club had been released today i
think rightly
it would be criticized for 90 of the
movie is showing how cool brad pitt is
when
like i think you're correct in saying
that the point is that
that part of you has to die but the
movie's not very clear about
that being the most important part of
the of the
to the last movies that's kind of where
the dostoevsky and quality of the movie
comes in and i mean that really
literally because i like the phone quite
a bit and i like
vintage's filmography because the thing
about dostoevsky right is
the alternative the bad thing always
neat i'm just gonna use this really
simply the bad
alternative always needs to be presented
in its most attractive form
you know ideologically physically
whatever because it's only once you kind
of kind of take that down
and you realize why it's appealing to
people that you can understand why it is
that it needs to be
firmly rejected even it's kind of most
seductive and emphatic
uh formulation but does that mean yeah
does that also that also raises the
question too like
you know if that movie was made today i
agree with you pills that like you know
it would be pretty uh
it would be people would be like what
like this is glorifying but i mean
that also makes me think like today do
we just have like a lower tolerance for
movies that aren't making the actual
moral message more obvious like do we
just because
of our age of like more politically and
morally charged things it's like we have
to have movies just be really clear
because
that's what i hate about movies today is
just going to say
it's always baked in there's like no
obvious but that's
because of this influence from the
reactions that these films get
is you glorified or you platformed or
you made this look attractive to
impressionable youths
so now we have to make it even like
obvious because if not like
there's there's this word there's it's
almost like there's an underlying um
like kind of like consequentialist
argument that we're now so worried about
the consequences
i mean it does i mean a little bit
tangential but it does raise like an
interesting conception of human nature
that like
the liberal ideal is like feels like or
the sort of locust idea has this
this this assumption that human beings
are so fragile that their minds are so
fragile that like anything can
can infect them and we have to we have
to free them of that risk it's like it's
like an
it's like it's like an intense
moralistic risk aversion
yeah like has anybody seen the movie
star i'm sure you've all seen the movie
starship troopers yeah and this is based
on a property
uh robert highland marvel that was
viciously
fascist and the satire couldn't be much
more heavy-handed right like
at the end neil patrick harris literally
shows up in a nazi outfit
uh and it's like look at the bugs the
bugs are afraid
and in the middle of the movie there's
this long depiction about how the human
beings yeah we were kind of colonizing
their planet and killing them
but they shouldn't have [ __ ] struck
back so you know what let's go
that's honestly an underrated movie and
at the time people thought it was a mind
based like action movie and they totally
missed the satisfaction well
it was accused of being fat pro like pro
fascist but i think but i think you so
you actually have it a little bit
in reverse so like the truth is that
heinlein was actually pro fascist his
novel
wasn't really it was like yeah so his
novel was actually like kind of
glorifying fascist potentials and the
director of the movie
turned it around and made it a satire of
fascism
okay that's different then that changes
things a little bit that's a dutch
director isn't it
he's a guy did robocop and then also a
total recall yeah that's for hovind yeah
oh yeah the director yeah yeah right
yeah he's the dutch guy
and he flipped it around and it's
actually it's delightful that movie is
actually still i think
or sorry the book is actually still
required reading for the us marine corps
or it's like one of the lists on the
of the books like the us marine corps
readings like ender's game
i mean it glorifies the the novel
glorifies like
like fascistic values of like
self-discipline and like how we need to
like
and and it kind of like makes these
arguments for why we actually need
uh like that citizenship can't be
afforded to to like everybody you have
to be like
a military person and like but then the
movie kind of like makes fun of the
whole thing and it
is actually i think that that is art at
its best
function is doing that kind of stuff not
and even if you even if some people miss
the point like they did with fight club
and i'm not saying fight club
is great art i think i the jury's out on
that but
yeah yeah but to take to take a
fascistic piece of literature and to
reverse it
and have only like a third of people
recognize that
and then have it like just appear as
this uh banal
action like let's kill aliens movie yeah
i think that's really clever
so do i i think i think some of the like
some of the tendencies
to want film to avoid like these sorts
of conflicts gets a little bit out of
hand because i
i think there is really great potential
for you know these again these cultural
products to explore
political and historical issues and
bring them to light
in a way that makes i don't know even
just raises awareness in the general
public
and i can think of a couple examples uh
the
the series version of the watchmen
brought a lot of attention to the tulsa
massacre
and for some reason something to do with
trump's twitter account as well
but that engaged these issues in a very
striking way as did the other series
lovecraft country
really stages like racial classism
in the early americas and then you have
movies like get out is it called and
other like some of jordan peels
films and those ones i mean like
in a way those ones more than the others
they really hit you over the head with
this post-colonial message
but i think that that is a good way to
go with it
like just because you're gonna piss off
conservatives who have a certain
idea about american history and don't
like it questioned that way
and of course hollywood has the idea
built into it that these
movies need to appeal to as many people
as possible which is why half of the
superhero movies are
rated [ __ ] pg is because they don't
want
them to be limited to an older audience
they want
everyone to be able to enjoy them
because they like everyone's money
it doesn't matter where the money comes
from if it's money it's good for me
so but these these other film i think
there's great potential that
should be explored more and even like
okay some people are going to interpret
it as
moralizing you're you're just
formulating this liberal law of the
father and trying to impose it on me
okay fine but it's still worthwhile i
think instead of
again just slipping back into this like
apolitical trash movies with terrible
aesthetics
and just cgi orgies well i i think
i'm going to defend david fincher and
paul verhoeven here
a little bit um by the way thank you
victor i did not know that the heimlich
novel was originally fascistic somebody
told me that i was anti-fascistic but
the movie definitely is right but i
think that there's something
useful even psychoanalytically useful
about forcing you to kind of
work through the artistic material to
get to this satirical message
because it resonates a little bit more
if you're actually able to go through it
that way because you understand why it
is that something like this might be
appealing
but at the same time there's this
psychoanalytic unmasking that takes
place at the end
where all these people who present
themselves as macho icons
are literally revealed as either being
shallow narcissistic or in the case of
tyler durden
literally unreal like without substance
right he just exists in your head
right and i love get out you know i love
jordan peels films both of them
and i think uh kmp is also great
uh so there's definitely a place for
things that are a little bit more on the
nose
satirical in that sense
but i don't want to do away with these
ones that a little bit more
difficult difficult uh and subversive
in that respect because i do think that
there's value in having to work your way
through that
yeah i this is my point about fight club
is i don't think it is
subversive it's mostly masturbatory over
the tyler durden character and most
people didn't get that wrong
yeah like something i mean one thing
that does the anti-hero much better
would be paul thomas anderson's there
will be blood because
okay yeah like that that is both a
sympathetic
and abhorrent character every single
character in there is
sympathetic and abhorrent at the same
time plus it has these themes of like
the
father and son and all those like weird
redux biblical [ __ ] but it does it well
at every point
there's no here's what you should get
out of it but it's about you know early
capitalist america so oh i have another
one
uh american psycho the uh i think it's
mary herron film the one with christian
bale
right that's another one that a lot of
people misinterpreted because the
director says
has everyone here seen it the american
psycho with christian i've seen it for
sure
she said she still gets emails every day
from people who are like
man i [ __ ] am patrick bateman it's so
[ __ ] cool
he's just like the [ __ ] raddest bro
and she's like
the movie literally ended with him
sitting there not even knowing what's
real anymore and just saying like i am
completely alone
uh and that's after it opens with him
being like i am completely
substance-less there's just nothing to
me
no joy no happiness no nothing yeah that
one really
in indicts wall street culture in a way
that wolf of wall street does not
it is that that is but that is that is
more subtle i think than fight club uh
sure but i think it's also a great
deconstruction of these kind of
fascistic tropes
in people you know what i mean and it's
kind of a testament to the fact that
they're so ingrained in our collective
unconscious right now
i'll go there right that people can't
really recognize that they're being
satirized any longer
yeah but i think the reason why fight
club isn't as successful like is because
like from my recollection right like
their whole goal is to blow up
so like they end up succeeding so like
because even like the tyler durden
character is like
his plan is to do that like bombing
right and then yeah he kills tyler
durden
but they still succeed so it's like so
like the goal
is still presented in the movie as being
like the objective that we want so it's
not all it's not actually that clear
and it's like he needed to do that right
he needed tyler jordan
to fulfill the plan so there's
definitely an easy way of reading that
movie as like not as actually saying
like like having a positive image of the
energy that the durden
character and like psyche within him had
that's true that might be a mistake then
in the film maybe i think about it we've
done that yeah
think about desire okay think about what
when we're taking psychoanalysis and
we're looking at literature
film what we're looking at is the
narrative as a kind of
adventure a desire adventure and the
main character wants something
right and you have to delay the
satisfaction of that desire until the
end of the film
and all the twists and turns that your
that the sort of progression of images
takes
that's the adventure of desire itself
what does he want
in the beginning of the film he's
working as shitty office job
he's got major insomnia problems
beaujolais fans eat your heart out
because everything looks like when you
have insomnia a copy of a copy of a copy
and he wants to break out of this sort
of somnambulant
sleep world into a real political world
with people and underground [ __ ] going
on and real stuff happening
real events not these fake events that
are just copies of earlier ones
but real [ __ ] and tyler durden
is a kind of product of modern culture
we're all like little bartleby's stuffed
in our cubicles and we're all asleep
and then lo and behold eventually
something happens
something some dark force awakens within
us
and we become well schizophrenic more or
less but really split personality i
guess you could say
and some voice begins talking to us and
telling us to do things and it becomes
liberating
but to an extent because eventually it
becomes you know
it becomes uh social it becomes
oppressive it becomes it doesn't
fit it dr it wants to push you too far
you give your it an inch and it'll take
a mile
right so eventually you have to sort of
kill it and
have that symbolic resolution where you
balance your
original desires with the new
realizations that you
acquire throughout the film or
throughout your life
and in the end hopefully become a
well-adjusted person
or somebody who's less [ __ ] up and
less asleep
in the end and that's the idea of
bringing
psychoanalysis to film is narrative as
desire
and the desire is a chain of signifiers
images whatever you want to call it
and so it's it's it's the same with
with fight club with any other movie and
it's really instructive to look at it
that way i think all right to get back
to our main plot as we are
uh we're not at time we can we can make
this one a little bit longer but
um to get back to the main point was
what does uh i think we've all kind of
just instinctively fell
into acknowledging that film has an
instructive function and we've all kind
of accepted that
my little bit of a push against that
would be do you really think that films
have this instructive function that we
think we do that we think it
should do we will actually learn
anything from it or is it just like
temporary catharsis to go back to the
plato aristotle distinction because i
don't think anyone here is coming out
saying
we should censor art i don't think
anyone has
even suggested that even a movie is
horrendous as uh
the zack snyder cut but uh if we if
if it's supposed to be instructive is it
instructive to actually be
some sort of effective thing or is it
really just
kind of an art for art's sake a super
level
skin on top of culture or would there be
art that you say like that shouldn't
exist
and we we need to keep that away from
the youth i ki i kind of think that like
it's the effect that art has on the
society like i tend to be a bit of a
skeptic about that and like i tend to
think
maybe more along the lines of like a
zizek that really art is more of a
reflection of what's going on in the
society and of course there's a feedback
effect
obviously like there is some but i think
the more the much
stronger relationship is really like
society
and then art reflecting what's happening
in the society as opposed to
society having a strong effect or sorry
the art having a strong effect on the
society
yeah i tend to take the jamesonian line
which is exactly what victor said which
is
that art is more of a reflection society
than a determinant of society
i would sometimes like to think uh that
art can have
a greater power than that and i think in
some rare historical moments it has
right there's very few people who deny
that something like uncle tom's cabin
for example
didn't have a profound effect in
motivating people to look at slavery
more seriously
right uh or that something like um
a room of one's own by virginia will
then gradually start to push culture in
a more feminist direction
but i think those examples are extremely
rare to kill a mockingbird right or
whatever
yeah all that stuff yeah exactly i think
those examples are extremely rare though
um
you know and that's probably why they
stand out in their mind but i think
i think that that like the the
relationship that's actually maybe why i
tend to
be a little bit more skeptic of the of
the of the locust
like uh like decree because i think it's
it's premised on
a very strong relationship from the art
to the society because i think they're
perceiving a very grave risk
that like that the art is actually is
actually perpetuating these things
in like an urgently strong way and it's
like that's why we have to excise
all these stereotypes in movies because
it's gonna perpetuate in the
whereas i think that like yeah maybe a
little bit but i really think the much
stronger
impact is from the society to the art as
a reflection of the society than
the other way around i don't think we
want to entirely say that there's
nothing
to be gained from a critique of art
because our let's call it reactionary
art
which isn't as pill said you know to
suggest that it should be censored in
any way shape or form because i don't
think it should
i i think it should be criticized and
analyzed uh and scrutinized carefully
uh but is this actually going to change
anything
uh i'm not really all that sure it's fun
though i mean we've all had a [ __ ]
good time here talking about
movies shitty and more interest um
movies on the shitty uh to the more
interesting spectrum so
i don't know i i i have a little bit of
trouble with the idea that
art is really just a reflection of
society
just because it like that idea seems
a lot like you know the
representationalist thing
where you know society is a certain way
and art is nothing in itself it just
reflects the way society is
and i think that's true to a degree but
the story is a little more complicated
than that
because it kind of takes away what is
unique and interesting about art
and human ability to make art and art
can
change the course of events and i'm
including
when i say art i'm including films and
radio broadcasts and podcasts and all
sorts of
like new art as well as classic art like
whatever music painting
symphony music i guess i should say but
i think i think art is
is something and it's creative and it
can change
the way the world is thinks
and the best kind of art when you treat
it like a reflection of society what
you're really saying is like whatever i
see in that artwork is the way society
is and i think the best
works of art resist you projecting
your fantasies onto it right that's what
the best kinds of art do
because it's it's ambiguous it's
indeterminate when you come out of a
film
and it's not a piece of [ __ ] but you can
still say like i don't know what the
[ __ ] i just watched
and maybe you have to think about it for
a while maybe you have to watch it again
later it's resisting
your ability to just smoothly interpret
it if it was a pure reflection
of society what it is what that is to
say is everyone in the audience is just
seeing exactly what they want to see
and i think that's like the capitalist
ideal of art that everyone can go and
just see
exactly what they want to see and then
go home might just sit in a theater with
a giant mirror on the wall and not even
play a show
that's what pop art or pop like movies
do i agree with you i mean i would i
would just like say that
i definitely think i was more when i was
originally making my point i was saying
that if it's one or the other if it's
either
like if if one is more dominant than the
other i would say that like the effect
that art has on society seems to me
when you include all the pop art right
like all the stuff that is just being
fed
by mass media to people that is just
like a reflection of what they want to
see or their ideological kind of like
fantasies or whatever
but yeah i agree i think that's a really
good point i don't think either of you
would argue it's a
pure reflection because it's uh latent
with fantasy
but then the the psychoanalytic category
for that is the dream
so the cinema of a time is the dreams of
that time which include
both repression and uh kind of scrub
self-image
both at the same time so you have like
leave it to beaver america
which was never real america but it was
what some people wanted to
believe that america was and then you
can you know psychoanalyze
i don't know psycho or something like
that i just wanted to say one thing
though
and maybe this is a reflection of the
fact that victor and i both come from
political background
uh rather than one that's more cultural
studies oriented because i actually
think uh that the mirror
analogy uh says a lot about where great
art finds its power
because i think of the most influential
kinds of arc uh as being those that
actually held up an accurate mirror to
society
and show it without this kind of
fantastic qualities attributed to
it i think of something again like uncle
tom's cabin or
oliver twist um or homage to catalonia
the orwell books right
uh what they force you to kind of say to
do is say look
the society that you fantasize about is
actually really pretty [ __ ] ugly
right there's a lot of ugly things in it
that you have been trying to ignore and
i'm now going to shove your face into
them
and you're going to actually look at
them hard rather than trying to avoid
them
because you know no matter how hard you
try to sneak up on the mirror it's
always going to look straight back
at you and i want you to face that right
uh and that's a little bit different
than
our eric's preferred aesthetic approach
uh which tends to emphasize ambiguity
right uh as a kind of reflective moment
uh that encourages you to think about
things critically
i think there's a lot of value in that
art also maybe it's just coming from a
political science perspective
well i tend to like that the more
reflective kind of art more
mirroring or i think the reason that
it's made that this stuff is art
in the first place though is to make it
so you don't have that kind of encounter
that you're talking about art is the
screen
that doesn't actually allow you to feel
the weight
of you know how awful everything is it
allows you to filter it
and the screen the mirror is the
symbolic
right like the image on the mirror is
just the imaginary the the fantasy
and the point of lacanian psychoanalysis
is to help you see the mirror itself
things like cracks in the mirror smudges
on the mirror things that aren't being
reflected
properly things that are being distorted
you know when you look at art from a
certain period like okay in the 1930s
for example i go back to hollywood
and i understand that there was a
depression and i understand in the
united states there's something called
the dust bowl
and a lot of people were [ __ ] upset
and yet
you look at 30s cinema and it's so it's
so
decadent and full of things like crime
and sex and drugs and all that sort of
stuff
like how is that a reflection like you
have to look at the distortions that the
mirror is presenting you
not the reflective thing and so like
political science or not i mean culture
studies everything is political
anyhow in culture studies so
in a sense we both just have different
views
of art and not determined by backgrounds
yeah the point of the dream or the point
of the mirror
is that there really is no mirror
without cracks in it the cracks are
fundamental
to it that's the thing i think the the
cracks in the mirror
are what and and obviously that's a
motif too they really just they smash
mirrors to show that the person is
fragmented in their identities or that
they don't know really who they are and
they're rejecting some world
that's being imposed upon them but
that's what art really
should do i guess from a lacanian
perspective is try to
show you the mirror itself and not
just the image fantasy that's on the
mirror
that just reflects you back to you yeah
i think that's right i
i mean i when i originally made the
point i think i i mentioned like
agreeing with zizek which i think is is
in line with with what you're saying if
unless you disagree with that but that's
kind of well you both
said i was mashing both of your
responses together yeah yeah but
but just quickly i do want to like like
agree with
your earlier point eric that like you
know art like making room i guess i want
to strongly agree with making room that
art can sometimes be that
that thing that like creates a different
like a really different unique
experience the creativity
but that's obviously very rare like i
think those kinds of that kind of
artwork is
is quite quite rare and and it ends up
being like you know a notable
moment in in the history of art when
someone creates something that is truly
creative
and unique um but most of the time like
pop art pop culture
is i think functioning much more as sort
of like this distorted reflection
uh that can be interpreted in various
ways of what's happening in the scene
yeah
zhizhak's good at that in the ideology
films or in the
in the uh perverts guide films is saying
like when we all had the experience of
watching the titanic together we thought
oh what a beautiful love story and gigi
goes actually it's a story about class
distinctions and
and the way that the working class will
just be thrown off into the icy water
while the rich lady gets to survive
and and he's right he's like those were
the cracks in the mirror of the
of the movie that nobody paid attention
to because it's like
like oh dicaprio oh everything's so
beautiful and aesthetically pleasing but
then
he points to those little cracks in a
movie that potentially seems to want
have had no cracks and no aesthetic
imperfections
welcome i just want to point out that
when i was talking about this kind of
mirroring functioning of art
i'm not talking about 1930 cinema or
superhero phones right again i was
talking about
great works of art that serve a kind of
political purpose and
i'll give you an example of something
like james baldwin right uh
who wrote some tremendous work uh pieces
um
advancing the cause of civil rights you
know through the 1950s and the 1960s
and in a lot of civil rights art there's
a kind of realistic quality to it
right that some people might criticize
is aesthetically unsophisticated next to
students and say post-modern earned
right people like thomas pynchon or don
delillo but the reason why they chose to
write the way that they did
is because they're trying to say look i
want to expose you to the fact that
beneath the kind of shiny veneer that
you're presented with
in all this kind of vulgar art you live
in a society that's defined by these
very deep injustices and the reason why
it is that they perpetuate themselves
is because a lot of the people who
support them
are motivated by some very ugly
pathologies like one of the things that
baldwin talks about is how it is that
whites are actually really degraded
through racist policies because they
come to depend on the sense of
superiority they get
from racism uh as a kind of affirming
their identity which is one of the
reasons that they find it
so difficult to give that up and in this
kind of moment what i think you really
see is a kind of exposure
in the psychoanalytic sense right where
it's forcing you to confront
what you've been trying to deny or
obfuscate the entire time
and this kind of realism is actually
really politically powerful
right in a way that ambiguity might not
it provides clarity
uh moral and social clarity if you will
that's been obfuscated by ideology and
that's not to say that some
realist art can't be really vulgar
especially if it becomes
you know logic and facts type realist
art you know or whatever it happens to
be or
socialist realism but i think pizza is
an art like you know invisible man
to kelly mockingbird victor mentioned
right or baldwin
you know do you perform this function
really well yeah well i can tell you the
the 1930s films did really serve a
political purpose afterwards
when the uh the christian conservatives
got a hold of them and they had that
they made enough noise to have an
entire code adopted by hollywood which
was roundly mocked by all the liberal
newspapers and magazines
and yet it happened and then we have
pre-code and postcode hollywood
so that i mean i guess sometimes you
have to look outside of the film
for the political ramifications as well
you wanna know something funny about the
movie titanic uh
i was obsessed with that movie when i
was younger by the way and so was my
brother but
if you notice kate winslet shows one
breast in that movie
not the other one and the reason for
that is
the movie code where you're if you want
a pg-13 rating you're allowed to show
one breast and you're allowed one swear
word no more
two gets you an r rating two swear words
gets you in our rating but one of each
that's okay yeah that was that was
internalized by the
film industry which is which is
presumably liberal
in its leanings but i mean that's
that's a conservative origin of the haze
code
they had to appease the christian
conservatives who were whose kids were
going to watch the movies so they had to
create a raiding system
yeah like one breath your kid may have
one breast
and but not yeah but no no more than one
and no less than
two well back to the superhero movies
this is why logan is the best one
because
of course always you want to see
wolverine's blades
actually go through someone's head but
you never get
the penetrative back to psychoanalysis
you need the penetration so you need to
see it actually go through someone's
face
like in logan which is what made it the
best x-men movie
so oh and it was closure too it was like
holy [ __ ]
it's like an ending of some kind
we do those speaking of endings speaking
of endings
hey great segue is it over
yeah my beers are empty so there is no
sequel
my masculine energy feels drained
yeah we need to uh get some of that bull
testosterone
anyway uh we hope you enjoy the uh this
edition of the red red pill podcast
um go watch the snyder cut if you are a
glutton for
punishment or if you're 13. if you could
smoke a lot of weed before you did it it
might also be helpful
i mean i could see my my enjoyment of
the film
increasing with each toke that i took
but we pretty much
spoiled it we did a lot of
psychoanalysis we didn't actually get to
sociology almost at all but that's okay
um
and i didn't expect this to turn into a
film studies episode because i don't
know if
i mean that's definitely not my area of
expertise
we'll just uh cut it off there speaking
of ends
this is from pills victor
i'm eric bye
all right take care everybody
[Music]